[Musique]
jeudi soir cyril avait décidé de réunir
tous ces éditorialistes sur un même
plateau pour débattre des nouvelles
mesures gouvernementales faso
coronavirus va revenir sur les annonces
du gouvernement c'est le grand débrief
parmi eux jean nessia mouniama j'oublie
stéphane manigold ou encore fabrice di
vizio à casting cinq étoiles et
prometteur en terme de débats débat qui
a tourné court pour fabrice division qui
n'a pas supporté les attaques de ses
camarades autour de la table vous faites
la diarrhée verbale et cadets
juridiquement vous vous pourrez d'aidé
mais qui sont bord du gouffre accusé de
complotisme en contestant les chiffres
officiels l'avocat a décidé de quitter
le plateau durant l'émission déjà sur
twitter m di vizio avait suggéré l'idée
de ce départ et si je me tirais de ce
plateau de dingue
chiche je vais le faire le lendemain le
docteur laurent alexandre était venu sur
notre plateau pour dénoncer les propos
complotistes de fabrice di vizio ce sont
des propos diffamatoires et scandales
qui auraient été tenus alors selon vous
fabrice di vizio est-il un complotiste
le traité de complotiste c'est trop
facile qui nous donne son droit de
réponse ce soir dont un pmp est en tout
cas merci à vous deux d'être là ce soir
fabrice di vizio merci laurent alexandre
merci d'être là tous les deux ont fait
de nombreuses émissions ensemble on est
pour le dialogue bien entendu et c'est
vrai que là
vous avez dit laurent élections j'avais
qualifié fabrice di vizio vendredi dans
notre émission de complotiste quand vous
prenez ce mot de complotiste fabrice je
le prends d'abord il veut rien dire je
pas ce que c'est qu'un complotistes ça
c'est le premier point mais le deuxième
point c'est pas tout à fait juste ce que
vous dites
laurent alexandre a pas exactement mac
mac à l'etna pas qualifier de quoi il a
qualifié les propos que vous lui avait
rapporté comme étant les maires de
complotiste or ce que veulent avait
rapporté les fasse comme j'ai dit que
c'est moi quand je m'embrouille et moi
je suis en train de dire que j'ai vu
l'émission est ce que vous lui avez dit
n'est pas ce que j'ai dit je vais te
dire moi je suis un fouteur de merde
alors on va on va on va reprendre ce que
vous avez dit fabre et des vidéos parce
que ça intéresse une dernière les
téléspectateurs
parce que c'est vrai qu'on est on essaie
de vous divertir tous les soirs et c'est
vrai que là on a vécu notre premier
week-end de confinement pour 16
départements il ya beaucoup de gens qui
ont très peu le moral et c'est vrai que
vous avez dit que cette décision de
reconfirmer n'était pas la bonne
samoussas voilà je résume bien et que
pour vous les chiffres des réanimations
parce que ce qui a poussé art confiné
c'est bien sûr le nombre de lits en
réanimation qui est bien sûr qu'ils
aient passé important donc forcément le
gouvernement était dans une situation
d'urgence et deux vers confiné pour
essayer d'avoir moins de gens en
réanimation et vous vous dites que ces
chiffres sont gonflés c'est pas
exactement ce que je dis alors la
question de l'iran c'est comme ça c'est
un fait dès le départ pas tarder à me
faire chier bien mais c'est intéressant
note alexandre il ya une question qu'il
faut se poser est que je pose aux
médecins c'est quoi un lit de
réanimation
commençons par le commencement c'est
quoi un lit de réanimation alors que
cissé l'hydra des nations aux critères
pour confiner faut commencer par définir
serristes autant il faut commencer par
définir c'est quoi un lit de réanimation
une définition administrative des oui
mais vous la donne et qui ont certains
attribuent certaines capacités
d'oxygénothérapie de monitoring des
patients et qui sont dans un
environnement où il ya un personnel
nombreux pour des malades a fait alors
pas tout à fait c'est tout le problème
jusqu'en février 2020 donc au début
crise le mot réanimation ça voulait dire
lits pour accueillir des patients avec
des défaillances multi organique
nécessitant une assistance respiratoire
voilà donc ça c'était encadré
aujourd'hui quand on vous dit il ya 5000
personnes en réanimation vous dites bat
pour faire simple j'ai cinq mille
personnes
un tube et puisque c'est ça ben sauf que
non c'est sa toile relève quoi parce que
entre les deux le mort des animations a
changé définition et on inclut dans le
mot réanimation soins intensifs les
soins continus or si j'ai bien 5000 lits
de réanimation en france j'ai treize
mille lits de soins intensifs les soins
continus premiers éléments et qu'est ce
qu'on apprend par santé publique france
que 48 % des patients en réanimation
d'un en réanimation sont hauts faits
sont en réalité en soins intensifs
donc ça veut dire quoi c'est que en
réanimation
je n'ai pas 5000 patients j'en ai 2005
et le reste est donc en soins intensifs
et en soins continus et donc je
m'interroge c'est une question
compliquée ce qu'on va devoir répondre à
ça alors j'attends des andes et au delà
des problèmes administratifs et de
définition des lits
ce qu'on observe pragmatiquement c'est
qu'on a dans certaines régions une
saturation et une augmentation des mains
d'emma des malades graves banon si banon
et qu'on a même un rajeunissement et
contrairement à ce que tu dis il ya un
rajeunissement depuis sur les six
derniers mois la rage issement de deux
ans de l'âge moyen des genres et à
ressources source
c'est le cas la perche a sorti les
chiffres sur le rhin sur le
rajeunissement
la moyenne d'âge en réanimation au rang
elle est effectivement aujourd'hui
en gros elle a été de 63 ans jusqu'ici
l'âge médian elle est effectivement on
est d'accord de 61 ans et demi
simplement tu imagines bien que la
différence ne te permet pas de dire
rajeunissement de la population 202 en
médecine c'est un mal au niger
vieux vais pas dire que ça l'esprit
c'est pas mais selon moi j'étoufferai le
savoir les téléspectateurs intéressant
c'est les chéris juste on a confiné
parce qu'apparemment on était en
saturation en réanimation
est ce que c'est vrai est ce que c'est
faux laurent alexandre c'est ce que va
le savoir les français ce que l'on lui
se retrouvent confinés les suces corps
de chiffres bien sûr ça les intéresse
mais ils veulent couper la réalité voilà
la réalité à la vérité c'est qu'on sait
qu'on a confiné pour parce que la
cocotte-minute commençait à chauffer un
peu trop et que comme on va pas avoir
beaucoup de vaccins dans les prochaines
semaines
on peut pas compter sur la vaccination
pour casser l'épidémie est donc en
réalité on en revient au fait que le
gouvernement a pris peur parce que il ya
moins d'astrazeneca que prévu il ya
moins de vaccins que prévu et donc le 15
avril on aura toujours que 10 millions
de français qui ont reçu une injection
alors qu en angleterre à ce moment là on
sera à 25 millions et les etats unis
aussi se rattraper ça y est le le le
gouvernement a pris peur parce qu'il a
pas de doses vaccinales pour casser
l'épidémie et donc il a confiné on
aurait pu ne pas confiné mais il aurait
fallu avoir un tout petit peu plus de
doses vaccinales et l'affinement on peut
sortir dans la rue soucy tous à vouloir
on n'a plus le choix de façon
politiquement aujourd'hui un confinement
dur on dirait à des émeutes dans
plusieurs pays européens en ce moment
donc là ce qui est fait le confinement
l'île de france c'est le maximum qu'on
peut faire sans avoir des émeutes
regardez ce qui s'est passé les 6500
rigolo à mars à l'isle-adam un allez en
parler là dessus l'acceptabilité du
confinement aujourd'hui elle est devenue
vachement fort je veux bien qu'on dise
rse moi je veux bien qu'on dise alors
m'a alors dit nous vous alors moi je
veux qu'on dise tout et surtout
n'importe quoi mais les critères c'est
pas moi qui les fixe quand même le
gouvernement vous parle de saturation
des animations à l'ordre public france
santé publique prend sa santé publique
france chiffres censés devoir en passer
de 1400 là cette semaine quand même 21
21 mars 2004 sans admission en soins
critiques dont 1600 trs 1636 admission
en réanimation
sauf que quand on vous le présente en
vous le présente comme 2411 admission en
réanimation et cette question c'est pas
moi qui les soul ben wallace alors
pourquoi
le crime c'est quoi le but c'est buts
j'en sais rien c'est quoi le bol et je
me demande même attendait c'est le losc
sait exactement qui me différencie en
parlait du complotisme c'est exactement
ce qui me différencie c'est quoi tes je
suis pas là pour apporter des réponses
simples à des problèmes compliqués je
suis là au moins pour soulever les
canards dont vous êtes dedans vous êtes
comme un garanich arrive ma voiture
alors pas là où quelques jours le jeune
philosophe ont un point commun ils sont
les consciences d'une société toujours
bien rire et que si vous vous posez pas
les bonnes questions
vous apporterez jamais les bonnes
réponses qu est qu'aujourd'hui est ce
qu'il est normal qu'on vienne vous dire
qu on a 95 % regarder en ile de france
aujourd'hui en ile de france on vous dit
donné à rs d'hier quand vous dis à 116%
des taux d'occupation des lits de
réanimation
alors vous vous dites [ __ ] chez 116%
occupation on se dit finalement quand
vous faites le bilan quand vous regardez
un peu plus loin vous apercevez que le
taux d'admission enfin le taux
d'occupation est aurait été de 52 % le
reste sans soins intensifs en soi confie
gilles verdez c'est pas la même chose
être divisés jeudi soir j'ai fait partie
de ceux en étaient quelques-uns qui
tentait de calmer parce que vous étiez
énervé et je pense que j'ai fait une
erreur en vous retenez vous le dis parce
que c'est quoi le complotistes c'est
celui qui prend des faits qu'ils aient
tort pour inventer des théories tous les
patrons des services de youri j'ai
inventé tous les pas 3d
non non non non c'est par mail que j'ai
inventé les faits mais pas d'armes a
affirmé dès le départ on a un problème
si vous voulez pas mais déçu de finir
tous les patrons des services de
réanimation tous de paris et d'île de
france notamment disent on est en
surchauffe
on n'en peut plus aider nous a vus
autour d'elle effet vous dites ils
mentent
non c'est façon je te vous dites et
occident chose de marteau m le
gouvernement confirme pour sauver ma m
les soignants et les réanimations et
vous dites non à la division une cape
town dire mais vous voilà mais c'est
vrai on parle de complot vous faites
quoi vous dites voilà
non vous nous dites clairement les
chiffres que l'on vous présente sont des
mauvais chiffres
il faut qu'on a dit ça donc on a donc
donc vous dites voilà ut horaire
ce m mais pour toi quand on écoute
l'année tous les mettre tous les
médecins le disent ils on ne pourra pas
faire face si ça augmente encore quel
est l'intérêt du souvenir quel est votre
intérêt moi je veux comprendre pourquoi
vous dites ça atteignons française et
parce que dans la tête des gens c'est
quoi tout qu'est ce qu'ils disent voilà
et on nous dise après celui là il ya un
mensonge et donc c'est ça le complot
c'est quand on in 12 express et moi
finir c'est quand on inocule 12 mois
qu'on souffle sur des petites braises du
complot parce que les gens vous leur
mettez là mais un doute
l'express et complotistes non non mais
non alors pourquoi l'express a posé la
question libé c'est complotistes non
mais pourquoi lit mais fait un article
dessus au nom du droit à l'information
l'express fait la même chose et il vient
à personne l'idée n'est traité de
complotiste et quand moi je le dis tout
à coup je devrais effectivement me
justifier est ce que c'est à moi nous
justifier ouais c'est ce qu'annoncent
les fruits guillaume a pas madonna
m'énerve que à chaque fois qu'on donne
la parole à quelqu'un qui a une pensée
différente de celle qu'on nous imposons
disent que c'est un complotiste
attention complotistes ya des complots
dix qui disent vraiment n'importe quoi
sur le comique qui disent que s'est
déversée par des drones et c'est un
maître division c'est quand même des
teintes sérieux il l'a prouvé
regardez sur internet car il est venu il
a émis des doutes on l'a tous défoncés
parce que tous les médecins disaient ça
et après il ya eu des clous gouvernail
leaf avait raison il avait raison il
était à mesurer dans ce qu'il dit mine
de rien ils avaient raison d'émettre des
doutes
il a raison de se poser mais il n'y
avait pas aussi l'année un chiffre on
est dans une machine à des sanctions
exemplaires à répondre à votre division
apprend à faire entrer les
l'organisateur fallait l'un des
participants au carnaval de marseille et
du me mohamed oui franchement je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on n'est pas sur une
bataille de chiffres sur le nombre de
genres et à la décision de reconfirmer
est là pas uniquement été prise parce
qu'il y avait un excédent de 2,2 de gens
en réanimation
elle a été aussi prise parce qu'à une
saturation de d'un certain nombre de
services hospitaliers et parce qu'il y
avait la crainte d'une explosion avant
la généralisation de la vaccination du
nombre de cas effectivement m division a
raison sur un point nous ne sommes pas
en saturation absolue des réa est
d'ailleurs délivré à on peut en créer
assez facilement d'accord on peut mettre
des lits supplémentaires dans les blocs
opératoires
quant au nom n'est pas à saturation mais
on est à un niveau préoccupant pour les
équilibres des taux également obligé de
confiner des soigneurs jeu cher on
n'avait pas comme on n'avait pas
beaucoup le choix compte tenu du water
avril en effet c'est clair moi ce que je
comprends pas c'est que ça vous
intéresse pas cette question que ça nous
interdire que tu as fait qu'un sont à
risque c'est intéressant
gimenez vous dis et je comprends ce que
vous dites vous dit effectivement
attention à pas rallumé la mèche
finalement du complotisme oui c'est un
peu ça l'idée
absolument je comprends bien mais
simplement vous imaginez bien aussi que
c'est légitime de se poser des questions
et que finalement mission désamorcer à
mèche c'est facile il suffit d'apporter
une réponse
ce que personne ne fait pas assez et
donc forcément il est là le problème
c'est que moi depuis le départ je pose
des questions mais on n'a pas l'airé des
questions ouvertes
le gouvernement accueille répondre moi
j'ai adressé une lettre au ministère de
la santé si on arrivait quand la
situation dise au québec vous a répondu
luc et moi il m'a pas répondu
03 13 donc c'est vrai c'est la regarder
j'ai un autre exemple on vous explique
partout en ile-de-france est saturé très
bien je comprends hamadi loin et qu'il
faut aller envoyer des patients par
avion bien sûr ailleurs vous savez que
aujourd'hui le taux d'occupation de
réanimation en yvelines donc là où
j'habite et taudière 38%
effectivement à paris on a un ton qui
est différent et que j'ai cliqué et qui
est beaucoup plus important
moi je me demande pourquoi on prend des
mecs de paris pour les emmener je sais
pas où au bout du monde alors que dans
les yvelines
j'ai un taux d'occupation à 38% est ce
que cette question n'est pas légitime et
en fait là où vous commencez justement à
nourrir le complotisme c'est lorsque
vous refusez de vous poser des questions
parce que tout à coup vous dit on et si
je le dis je vais taxé de complotisme
mais non la vérité c'est que dans une
démocratie on se pose des questions
alors